Nos dicen que: "Rodrigo observa cómo despega
un helicóptero desde una plataforma. La altura
del helicóptero (en metros sobre el suelo) t
minutos después del despegue está modelada por",
y vemos esta función justo aquí, "Rodrigo
quiere saber en qué momento el helicóptero
aterrizará sobre el suelo". Así que pausa este
video y ve si puedes resolverlo. Muy bien,
ahora pensemos en esto juntos. Así que imaginemos
en realidad cómo se ve la gráfica de esta función,
y también nos ayudará a pensar qué está
pasando con el helicóptero. Entonces, nuestro
eje horizontal es el tiempo en minutos, t, y luego
nuestro eje vertical es la altura, y la altura es
una función del tiempo y se mide en metros sobre
el suelo. Ahora, no sé exactamente cómo se ve la
gráfica de esta función, pero dado que tengo un
coeficiente negativo en mi término cuadrático,
sé que es una parábola que se abre hacia abajo,
como esta, y dice que el helicóptero despega de
una plataforma, entonces cualquiera que sea la
altura de la plataforma el helicóptero despega
y hará algo como esto. No sé exactamente cómo se
ve la gráfica pero probablemente se vea algo así.
Ahora, si nos preguntaran cuál es el punto más
alto del helicóptero y en qué momento ocurre,
querríamos averiguar cuál es el vértice de
esta parábola, pero eso no es lo que nos están
preguntando, nos preguntan en qué momento aterriza
el helicóptero sobre el suelo, ese es el tiempo
justo aquí. Entonces, si quisiéramos encontrar
el vértice, querríamos poner esto en forma
de vértice, pero aquí queremos saber cuándo la
función es igual a 0, queremos encontrar un 0
de esta cuadrática, y la mejor manera que se me
ocurre para hacer esto es tratar de factorizarlo,
tratar de establecer esto igual a 0, después
factorizarlo y ver qué valores de t lo hacen igual
a 0. Entonces permíteme hacer eso: -3t² + 24t +
60. Recuerda que lo que nos importa es cuándo la
altura es igual a 0. Veamos, quizá lo primero
que haría para simplificar un poco el término
de segundo grado es dividir ambos lados entre 3
negativo, si hago eso esto se convierte en t²,
24 dividido entre 3 negativo, 8 negativo t,
60 dividido entre 3 negativo es 20 negativo,
y luego 0 dividido entre 3 negativo sigue siendo
0. Y ahora, ¿puedo pensar en dos números cuyo
producto sea -20? Deberán tener diferentes signos
para obtener un producto negativo y cuya suma sea
8 negativo. Veamos qué pasa con 10 negativo y 2,
y esto parece funcionar, así que puedo escribir
esto como: (t - 10) (t + 2) = 0, y así para que
toda esta expresión sea igual a 0 cualquiera de
estos términos tiene que ser igual a 0, entonces t
- 10 = 0 o t + 2 = 0, y por supuesto puedo agregar
10 en ambos lados, entonces t = 10 o podría
restar 2 de ambos lados aquí: t = 2 negativo,
por lo que hay dos lugares donde la función es
igual a 0: uno es el tiempo t = 2 negativo y otro
en el tiempo t = 10. Ahora, estamos suponiendo que
estamos tratando con tiempo positivo, no sabemos
qué hacía el helicóptero antes del despegue,
así que realmente no consideramos esto; lo que
realmente nos importa es que t = 10 minutos, es el
momento en el que el helicóptero está justo allí,
y en realidad sabemos que cuando t = 0, estos
dos términos se convierten en 0; sabemos que
despega a 60 m y sube, y si calculáramos
el vértice sabríamos qué tan alto llegó,
luego comienza a bajar y 10 minutos después del
despegue regresa a 0 y aterriza en el suelo.